Here's a surprise
about The White House.
The paintings come alive
at night
after I've taken
my anti-baldness medication.
Look who's
in the painting today.
It's President Andrew Jackson,
Old Hickory Dickory.
Let's see if we can wake him up.
Wake up! Wake up! Wake up! Wake
up! Wake up! Wake up! Wake up!
What? What is happening?
Where am I?
Why, this looks
like The White House.
And who might you be?
I'm the president.
Oh, boy, oh, boy.
I'm so glad you're here.
I told everybody that you would
have prevented the Civil War.
Uh, no, Mr. President,
I didn't fight in the Civil War.
I fought in the War of 1812.
18 to 12-- the forbidden years.
(laughter)
Okay.
The Civil War
was a total disaster.
Why did it have to happen?
I can't believe
I'm the only person
to ever ask that question.
And you were the only man
who could have stopped it.
I don't think that's true.
You know,
between my time in office
and the start of the Civil War,
there were nine
other presidents.
Also, I was dead.
No, no, no. No, no.
You would've prevented it.
Don't be modest.
I don't know what you're...
Well, I sent a war ship
to South Carolina
to enforce Federal law
against nullification.
Is that
what you're talking about?
Absolutely.
One of the greats.
Am I?
A lot of stuff I did
hasn't aged well.
(laughter)
I... I owned hundreds of slaves.
I legalized genocide
against the Indian tribes.
But in the end, you took
one look at the Civil War,
and you said,
"Not on my watch!"
Listen to me! I had nothing
to do with the Civil War!
I wasn't mad about it
because I didn't see it coming
because I couldn't have seen it
coming because I was dead!
(laughter)
-Is this your cup?
-What?!
I found this old cup,
and I said,
"This is definitely
Jackson's cup."
I've been drinking out of it
for weeks.
It's got to be yours.
I don't think so.
Are you sure
it's not your cup?
It's not my cup.
I think it's yours.
Okay, fine, it's my cup.
Is there anything
you want to say to cup?
Uh, hello, Cup.
I love this.
This is history come alive.
You know what?
Come out of the painting!
Well, this whole thing
is just a hallucination
caused by your anti-baldness
medication, so you're the boss.
All right, whatever.
-(applause and cheering)
-♪ ♪
-Andrew Jackson, everybody.
-(applause and cheering)
Andrew Jackson, everybody.
Sit where Mike sits.
Just sit where Mike sits,
right next to Cup.
Not my cup.
Do you have any questions
about the future,
President Andrew Jackson?
Sure. Are we still
at war with the Indians?
Sort of. We just ran
a rickety pipeline
through their sacred land.
Love that.
Um, what about slavery?
How did that all shake out?
Well, I hate to break it to you,
but there's no more slavery.
-Aw.
-But...
But we do have an incredible
prison industrial complex
that locks up black people
and makes them work for nothing.
Hey, pretty much the same thing!
Wow. See?
(applause)
Steve was right--
I am just like you.
You are way cooler than Mike.
PENCE:
Uh, sir? Sir?
Mike, where the hell are you?
Uh, trapped in the painting,
sir!
Oh, Jesus, Mike.
All right, yeah,
we'll get you out.
-Please.
-We're not gonna get him out.